the Joe Rogan experience for a long time
my operating theory on aliens was when I
see something that's interesting
then I'm gonna pay attention to it right
cuz it just it's too attractive and it's
part of the thing of whether it's RAM or
any of these wonky things
there's something about woowoo stuff
whether it's psychics or Chandler's
that's really attractive to people
yes I'm sort of a weird way and so is so
are aliens the idea that if we were
visited by something from another world
some far advanced space Daddy or
whatever it is that comes down here and
it's gonna show us the way that's that's
so attractive that it I think it messes
with your ordinary ability to observed
and to objectively analyze what's real
and what's not
yeah I totally agree with that and I
think it's an unfortunate feature of the
human mind that we tend to look outward
for weirdness that will inject into the
world more than the everyday that we
experience through through common
everyday encounters we want there to be
more we don't want it to be right that
were just on this rock around this
planet and we live for a while and then
we're gone we want it to be more than
that and so we imagine that there's some
answer floating out there in the cosmos
that maybe that will be brought down to
earth through our space daddy as you
refer to it and my view of that is it's
much more noble to recognize that there
is no answer floating out there in space
there's no space data that's gonna come
here and say this is what it's all about
the answer is you and I and everybody
else we manufacture our own meaning we
manufacture our own purpose and how much
better is it that we come up with the
our own meaning than having it bestowed
or forced upon us by some external
entity I don't think that diminishes
things I think it grand eise's them
because it's coming ultimately from
ourselves
that makes a lot of sense I think the
hope is that space daddy's gonna prevent
nuclear war and figure out how to fix
the ocean yeah sure no I mean and that I
could that I could certainly imagine
happen
there's knowledge out there in the world
that you could imagine that that we
haven't yet encountered that we could
make use of so fantastic but the other
thing that's worth keeping in mind and
this I think is surprising to some
people you can do a calculation as to
whether consciousness can itself persist
indefinitely in the universe you can ask
yourself sure earth may go away
you and I we're going to go away we
recognize all this but is it possible
that some kind of conscious being can
continue to cogitate indefinitely far
into the future or its progeny continue
to cogitate and you can pretty much
establish that thought itself will come
to an end
in this universe thought itself is a
limited lifetime phenomenon in the
cosmos so when at least our universe
right yes so I'm gonna focus just on our
down a protons when we get to that point
there's no room for thought no that's
part of it but I'm willing to go further
I'm willing to imagine that even with
the breakdown of protons that there's
some way that the particles that it
spawns electrons neutrinos photons
whatever somehow through some
configuration of widely-separated
particles is able to have signals going
back and forth that allows this group of
particles to think I'm willing to posit
that in order to be as general as
possible and with that assumption you
can still prove that the relentless rise
in entropy that we were talking about
before ensures that any cogitating being
that happens to still be able to persist
in this unusual realm of particles will
ultimately burn up in the entropic waste
generated by its own process of thinking
so the process of thought itself in the
far future will generate too much heat
for that being to be able to release
that heat to the environment and to
avoid burning up in its own waste when
you think you will fry it's it's always
been interesting to me when I've really
stepped back and looked at it that our
ideas of the importance of thought
so egocentric when we take into
consideration the the vast scope of the
universe and how majestic so much what
we see in the cosmos that there's no
thought at least as far as we know
whatsoever
like like hyper Nova's like like give
you know star nurseries all these
different things that we see in the
cosmos that are infinitely larger than
us and responsible for life itself yeah
that these processes create the very
elements that are needed to create life
but we're so concerned with this one
animal's ability to think and ponder
yeah create and and emotions and and
write stories and that to us it's so
egocentric how is that really
self-centered when you take a universe
yeah I mean we are to finite beings
sitting in the valley yeah you know in
front of a wooden desk ya know it's
really weird they don't think about it
as so important everything does it is it
is and it's hard to not think in those
terms but uh I encourage people the part
of the point of this book is to
encourage people to think in a cosmic
way and recognize the point that you're
making
yeah which are we these little tiny tiny
finite beings crawling around on this
planet we're here for a brief moment of
cosmic time and that's all there is to
it and some will feel like oh my god
that's disturbing that's distressing my
point is hey extol celebrate the fact
that you were here for this brief I mean
think about the collection of quantum
events stretching back from the Big Bang
until today that had to turn out exactly
as they did for you and for me to
actually exist each one of these quantum
events and there are nearly infinitely
many of them could have turned out that
way instead of this yielding a universe
in which neither you nor I nor anybody
else would be here and yet against those
astounding odds astounding odds we're
here that is cause for celebration and
you can go further not only over here we
can figure out how we got here we can
create art we can write the stories that
you are referring to we can create
comedy we can build monuments we can
create films we can do things that
inanimate objects can
so this to me is where the value and
purpose and meaning comes from as
opposed to trying to look out and hope
space that he comes with the answer of
you know flashing in neon sign saying
aha
that's what it's all about that's never
gonna happen it isn't what it might
yours but I admit that it's possible I
so every time I say it's not gonna
happen I mean unlikely that it's gonna
vary unlike yeah I agree with that
[Applause]